before diving in character-based
tokenization
understanding why this kind of
tokenization is interesting
requires understanding the flaws of
world-based tokenization
if you haven't seen the first video on
the word-based tokenization
we recommend you check it out before
looking at this video
okay let's take a look at
character-based tokenization
we now split our text into individual
characters rather than
words
there are generally a lot of different
words in languages while the number of
characters
stays low to begin let's take a look at
the english language
it has an estimated 170 000 different
words
so we would need a very large vocabulary
to encompass all words
with a character-based vocabulary we can
get by with only 256 characters
which includes letters numbers and
special characters
even languages with a lot of different
characters like the chinese languages
can have dictionaries with up to 20 000
different characters
but more than 375 000 different words
so character-based vocabularies let us
use fewer
different tokens than the word-based
tokenization dictionaries
we would otherwise use
these vocabularies are also more
complete than their word-based
vocabulary's counterparts
as our vocabulary contains all
characters used in a language
even words unseen during the tokenizer
training can still be tokenized
so out vocabulary tokens will be less
frequent
this includes the ability to correctly
tokenize misspelled words
rather than discarding them as unknown
straight away
however this algorithm this algorithm
isn't perfect either
intuitively characters do not hold as
much information individually
as a word will hold for example let's
hold
more information than its first letter l
of course this is not truthful for all
languages as some languages like
ideogram-based languages have a lot of
information held in a single character
but for others like roman based
languages the model will have to make
sense of multiple tokens at a time
to get the information otherwise held in
a single word
this leads to another issue with
character-based tokenizers
their sequences are translated into very
large amounts of tokens
to be processed by the model and this
can have
an impact on the size of the contacts
the model will carry around
and it will reduce the size of the text
we can use as input for a model which is
often limited
this tokenization while it has some
issues has seen some very good results
in the past
and so it should be considered when
approaching a new problem as it solves
issues encountered in the word based
algorithm